never needs to bundle up stay warm  because we have wind chill on top of  those gusty winds we expect for tonight  those winds have already started to  materialize at reed international look  at that gusts up to 21. temperatures in  the 50's to low 50's outside right now  of course it will get even colder here's  to expect tonight not only is a smoke  advisory due to this smoke from  fireworks we're looking at the high 40s  for tonight your gusts up to 30 miles  per hour may exceed that throughout the  evening but here are your windshield  readings in the low 40s to even the 30s  by the time we get to 10 p.m maybe as  early as 9 p.m and certainly in the  mid-30s by midnight showers stay to the  north we're looking at right now moving  from west to east into northern portions  of clark county hear your headlines  guess the end of 2021 a cold weekend  start to 2022 though and the morning  temps could be the coldest of the season  for the weekend